- [Interviewer] Okay, we are ready to go.
James, so where are you from originally?
- I'm from Texas.
- [Interviewer] Houston, right?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, Houston.
- [James] From Houston.
- [Interviewer] What
brought you out to LA?
- Music and acting,
I'm a singer songwrite.
So, I tried doing that
didn't work out too well
and then I tried acting.
So, that didn't work out too well either.
- [Interviewer] You got a great look.
(laughing)
You do, you do.
You should maybe think about--
- I did before I was homeless.
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] So, I've
seen you on the street here
like passed out face down on the sidewalk.
It's alcohol that's your
issue, not drugs so much?
- [James] Drugs and alcohol I guess.
- [Interviewer] Oh, drugs too.
- Yeah, I use meth
sometimes and then I drink
to come off the meth.
- [Interviewer] Oh, okay, wow.
- But, usually I'm up for
a few days doing meth,
then I'm going to pass out for
a day or two on the sidewalk.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yeah.
That's how I think I caught you last.
What age did you start with the drinking
and the drugs or whatever?
- I actually had a pretty good life
up until about my mid-twenties.
I used a little bit when I
was a teenager, you know,
I'd drink at parties with friends
and I did a few things
here and there, you know,
took some acid a little bit,
did a little bit of cocaine
when I was a teenager.
Then I quit using drugs
completely when I turned 18
and I was sober for
years until my twenties.
In my twenties I started drinking.
When I became legal to drink,
I started drinking again.
And then after drinking for a few years
I began using again, which
was something different.
It was crystal meth.
So, when I was about 25,
26 years old, 24, 25, 26,
right around there, I started
drinking and using crystal.
And so I've been using crystal
for about 10 years now.
I'm trying to quit because
10 years on crystal, I mean,
it really fucks you up really bad.
- You still look fairly healthy
and young? How old are you?
Before it fucks me up too bad I want
to fucking quit using.
- How old are you?
- 36.
- You look great.
You'll see some people
out here that are 48
and they look like 80.
- Yeah, but that's what
they say, you know,
10 years on crystal, you need to quit it.
You know, and that's
all the rumors I hear is
10 years on crystal man, 10 years,
10 years, you can't do it anymore,
you can't do any more.
It's gonna fuck you up too bad.
So, I'm trying to quit.
I've been trying to quit for a while now.
- And then alcohol is
also an issue for you.
- Not so much, alcohol
is not really the issue.
I don't think, I don't
think it's the issue.
I think maybe I use alcohol currently
because I get high on crystal,
I smoke too much of it
and then I can't sleep
or I can't get off of it or, you know,
so I drank to come down off of it.
- [Interviewer] Got it.
- But, drinking's never been the problem,
I don't think, I mean--
I have a problem with
drinking too. (laughing)
- [Interviewer] So, tell
me about your childhood.
Is there anything that you're trying
to not think about from your childhood
or do you think it's just,
you're more addictive than--
- My family was really abusive to me.
- [Interviewer] Oh, really?
- Like all of my family,
my brothers, my sisters,
my mom and my dad.
They were all abusive.
My father was physically abusive,
emotionally abusive to
everyone in the family.
He used to beat up on
my mom, shit like that,
beat up on us.
I went to school one day in fourth grade
and I had these like slashes
on my back of my thighs
and on my back,
I can't even remember
what my dad did it with.
It was either a wire
hanger or an extension cord
or his belt that had like
these Buffalo nickels on it.
I can't really remember
what he did it with
but I remember the incident
and I remember my father chasing me
with something around the house,
threatening me, backed me into a corner
behind my bedroom door and just started
and I turned my head into the corner
and he just went crazy
on my back and my legs.
So, my sister decided
it would be a good idea
to tell the counselor.
And then I had to go in,
and I was in fourth grade,
I was like nine or 10 years old,
I think 10 years old, I had
to go show the counselor.
And I was like, "God damn it."
You know?
So, my sister went and told the counselor
and the counselor called me in and said,
"Pull your pants down,
take your clothes off."
You know, "What'd your dad do?"
I was like, "Well, he hit me."
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] That's horrible.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And then when
you say your family as well,
was abusive.
- [James] Yeah, my family was
abusive towards me as well
because I had some trust
money I was getting
when I turned 18. So, they
were all jealous of it.
When I turned 18, I got some money
from an accident I was
in when I was a child.
And, so my whole family
was very abusive towards me
as soon as I got that money.
- [Interviewer] Do you still
have the money somewhere
or is it--
- [James] No, I spent it.
- [Interviewer] You burned through it?
- [James] Yeah, I burned through it.
It wasn't really a lot of money.
It's not like it was millions
or something like that, you know.
But, it was enough to get
me started when I was 18
and I went to college
a little bit and there
and when I came to California
I went back to college here in California.
I went to college here.
I had like three jobs.
I was waiting tables,
bartending and catering
and I was going to LACC
and I was in a situation with a roommate
that didn't work out too well
and I ended up homeless
because I didn't have any paperwork
at the residence I was staying at.
And he became jealous of
something for whatever reason
and I ended up being homeless.
So, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think that crystal meth
is keeping you from getting your together
and getting a job?
- Yeah, I mean, it's possible.
I've been on crystal for a while now.
So, I mean, it's possible that
that's definitely part of it.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What would
you like to see happen
for the next five years for you?
- I'd like to quit using crystal.
(laughing)
You know, I really want to quit using.
It's bad.
- You see what the future holds.
- And I've been using it for 10 years
and I know the rumors about crystal meth
in 10 years is that it starts
to deteriorate your body.
Your body starts to decay
your face, everything.
I won't have any teeth
in a couple of years
or something like that if I keep using it.
And, I mean, currently right
now, I still have my teeth.
(laughing)
- You're a handsome guy,
you seem like you could
just snap out of it
and be like nothing ever happened.
But five more years of that.
- Yeah, I can't continue using.
I know that.
So, I've been trying to quit.
- Yeah, good for you.
Excellent, well, thank you
so much for talking to me
and good luck out there, it's crazy.
- [James] Thanks.
- [Interviewer] These
things that hold onto people
in this neighborhood are so
dangerous and so destructive.
You see it.
Put everything you've got
into getting off this shit.
- Yeah.
All right, thank you so much.